y en directo Vamos hasta Turquía hoy se
cumple un año de los potentes terremotos
que devastaron a este país y también a
Siria hay que dejar Más de 52.000
personas muertas las labores de limpieza
de escombros siguen mientras cientos de
ciudadanos continúan desaparecidos unas
200 personas han sido procesadas por su
responsabilidad en la precaria
construcción de los edificios afectados
la gestión del terremoto es una de las
cuestiones que pueden marcar la
contienda de Cara a las presidenciales
de mayo hoy la coalición de oposición
turca declaró a
quemarroglu como su candidato para
enfrentar al presidente allí Perdón
ampliamos esta noticia con nuestro
corresponsal Adrián Rocha Adrián muy
buenas noches cuéntenos Cuál es la
situación en las regiones afectadas en
Turquía
pues la situación Es verdaderamente
terrible sobre todo en las regiones más
afectadas como lo es por ejemplo la
provincia de hatay en la capital de esa
provincia antárquia es donde han muerto
la mayoría de las personas por ese
terremoto que ocurrió hace justo un mes
en Turquía hoy mismo se cumple el primer
mes y de momento se calculan que son ya
más de 50 y 2000 personas las muertas
tanto en Turquía la gran mayoría
murieron en Turquía 46.000 como 6000 más
en el noroeste de Siria ahora mismo las
regiones afectadas la ayuda ha ido
llegando en sus últimos meses y hay
mucha gente que ha podido marcharse se
queda según nos explican pocas personas
se quedan en lugar sin embargo sí que
las personas que siguen ahí porque no
han podido salir o porque han intentado
regresar a lo que antes eran sus casas o
si aún mantienen estas se mantienen en
pie explican que la situación es muy
peligrosa que falta agua que en muchos
casos También faltan tiendas de campaña
para estas personas y que las personas
que pudieron volver a sus casas han
visto como muchas de ellas han sido
robadas sus contenidos ya que según nos
explican muchas personas de estas
regiones no tenían sus ahorros en los
bancos sino que los mantenían en casa
con dólares o bien oros según la forma
tradicional de guardar el dinero también
aquí en Turquía muchas de esas personas
explican que todos sus ahorros han sido
perdidos a través de bandas que ocuparon
sobre todo durante las primeras semanas
estos territorios afectados para
intentar robar los las pertenencias que
se habían quedado abandonadas dentro de
las casas de la gente
programadas para dentro de dos meses en
qué posición queda el presidente erdogan
entradas el terremoto
pues queda en una posición bastante
débil porque su popularidad anterior
antes del terremoto ya era algo
discutida Después de varios años de
crisis inflacionaria en Turquía según la
gran mayoría de los sondeos erdogan iba
a perder contra la oposición que había
sido galvanizada por esta baja
popularidad del gobierno del gobierno de
perdón y ahora lo es aún más porque
muchos turcos consideran que la
respuesta del gobierno fue tardía o fue
ineficiente e insuficiente según nos
explicaron en los lugares donde
estuvimos en algunos sitios sobre todo
en las zonas Rurales los equipos de
rescate la ayuda tardaron días incluso
semanas sin llegar en muchos lugares y
muchos turcos por lo tanto ven como
culpable un sistema que fue puesto por
el propio presidente Turco en 2017 tras
un referéndum en el que una persona él
mismo es quien dirige absolutamente todo
lo que ocurre dentro del Estado del
erdogan de hecho durante las últimas
semanas pidió una especie de perdón a
los ciudadanos turcos diciendo que
aceptaba que había habido algunos
problemas y deficiencias en la respuesta
del estado sin embargo también
he tenido a muchas personas por críticas
al gobierno además se ha cerrado foros
en internet por críticas este mismo
gobierno incluso cadenas opositores han
recibido multas y prohibiciones de
emitir por haber precisamente hablado de
las amnistías que el gobierno hizo para
las construcciones ilegales además de
otros proyectos que Podrían haber
causado que tantos miles de edificios se
hayan colapsado en el sudeste de Turquía